las fuerzas prorusas en la ciudad de
gerson anunciaron el fin de la
evacuación de civiles ante el avance de
las tropas ucranianas que buscan retomar
un punto clave que fue una de las
primeras zonas urbanas que perdieron
desde el comienzo del conflicto hace
ocho meses los combates no se detienen y
este eventual enfrentamiento amenaza con
recrudecer el conflicto
soldados ucranianos buscan recuperar
terreno
hay constantes bombardeos todos los días
por la mañana y por la noche durante
todo el día artillería bombas de racimo
aunque estén prohibidas bombardeos todos
los días
la lucha está en marcha escuchen estas
son bombas de racimo que explotan no sé
si la cámara graba el sonido Pero hay
fuego intenso explosiones de bombas de
racimo es duro pero los chicos lo
sobrellevan bien tienen el ánimo alto
Ucrania Ha logrado derribar varios
drones kamikaze utilizados por Rusia y
supuestamente de fabricación iraní
Aunque Te dirán niega que le hayan
vendido Estas armas a Moscú y
daño en la actualidad no sabemos Cuántos
drones ha recibido Rusia Y si fueron
entregados por transporte aéreo o a
través del mar caspio ha habido una
cotización oficial de que Rusia ordenó
2400 drones pero no se sabe este número
está disponible y si se puede producir
el número requerido por Rusia Esta es la
razón probable por la cual la intensidad
de los ataques con drones se ha reducido
un poco Okay
[Música]
Rusia por su parte anunció que había
terminado de convocar a reservistas para
luchar en la guerra tras haber reclutado
a unas 300.000 personas en un mes según
el kremlin una cuarta parte de ellos ya
estarían luchando en el frente